Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui dans ScienceClic, le plasma.
La matière peut exister à l'état
solide, comme l'eau dans un glaçon,
à l'état liquide,
et à l'état gazeux, comme la vapeur
d'eau.
La matière peut donc se présenter sous
3 états : Solide, liquide et gazeux.
Cependant, si l'on chauffe assez un gaz,
ou si on le soumet à une décharge
électrique assez puissante, il est
possible d'arracher aux atomes certains
de leurs électrons.
C'est ce qu'on appelle "ioniser" le gaz.
Ce gaz ionisé possède à présent
des caractéristiques très différentes
par rapport au gaz d'origine,
et ainsi on peut parler d'un quatrième
état de la matière : c'est le plasma.
Le plasma est une sorte de soupe, dans
laquelle baignent des électrons libres et des noyaux d'atomes.
Du fait de ces électrons libres, le
plasma est un fluide qui conduit
très bien l'électricité,
contrairement aux gaz.
Sur Terre la matière à l'état de
plasma est plutôt rare.
On en trouve dans la nature, sous forme de feu, d'éclairs, ou encore d'aurores boréales.
Mais le plasma est également créé et
utilisé par l'homme, comme par exemple
dans certains écrans de télévision.
Cependant, si le plasma est
relativement rare sur terre,
il compose près de 99% de tout l'univers,
par exemple sous la forme d'énormes boules de plasma,
Les étoiles.